all right let's see if we can get this
in the right position oh did you catch
that hey guys it's max with max Tech and
we just got our hands on the brand new
Galaxy S 10 plus which features an
underneath the displayed ultrasonic
fingerprint scanner now this is crazy
that these days we have technology like
this where you just touch the display
and it will unlock I don't have it set
up right now for me but my biggest
question is how secure is this new
technology it's moving forward so
quickly can we rely on it so to test
this out would even I created some
copies of his fingerprint now this is
very easy to do we take some tinfoil
some hot glue on it push in your
fingerprint let that cool down grab some
Elmer's glue fill it in because it has
to be the same orientation can't be
reversed let that dry and what you get
is a little fingerprint copy like this
now for this one we put some black
sharpie on it to kind of simulate some
maybe depth so just to prove to you that
there's nothing fishy going on here
let's try my fingerprint I don't have it
registered we only have Vadim's
fingerprint registered and along with
the SN plus we have the oneplus 60 that
also has a built in underneath the
display fingerprint sensor the
technology is a little bit different but
once again my fingerprint does not work
but even come on in here and show this
off that it does work on your since we
modeled go off of yours try that one
more time well obviously that works and
how about this one
there we go let's test this thing out
I'm gonna make sure I have this there
correct orientation all right
can you see this well it's taken a
second before vibrate says press a
little bit harder no match now if you
guys are familiar with this technique
people use this on the touch ID systems
on the iPhones and it did in fact work
so it is interesting that it's not
working here so let's switch over to the
1 plus 60 now and see how this fear is I
mean this fingerprint is really good it
turned out quite nice it's trying to
read it saying not recognized oh did you
catch that I can't believe it after we
get this warmed up a few times it will
literally just work basically each time
just like it's your own fingerprint so
just to prove that we're not doing
anything with cuts or anything like that
you guys see this fingerprints working
right no cuts now my fingerprint nothing
it's not recognized so we are actually
reading with our fake fingerprint here
and it's working every time on the
oneplus 60 that uses the optical sensor
underneath the display and with the
galaxy s 10 we cannot get it to work now
my next question is is it just picky
depending on the device or is it smart
enough and accurate enough to know that
that's not your right fingerprint so I'm
gonna see if I can add that fingerprint
to our authentication and see if we can
actually register this or is just this
plastic kind of what's stopping us so
let's add this new fingerprint okay
there it is so let's see if it'll work
and if we can actually unlock it if it
does that basically means that this
sensor is so precise that it could tell
a difference between beams actual
fingerprint and this kind of fake copy
of it and that would be a great thing
let's do the edges here cuz unbox
therapy just made a video showing off
how the face unlock on this phone isn't
very accurate and just playing back a
video and not very good video unlocks it
let's try it out here press a little
harder
and we have it it's now unlocking there
you go so what this means is that this
sensor this ultrasonic fingerprint
sensor underneath the display is very
accurate and now we have a very secure
method of locking our devices don't use
the face unlock use the ultrasonic
sensor and it also means that it's much
more secure than the 60 so BAM once we
add to this it is working and let's try
my finger there you go I didn't add
anything else in my fingerprint is not
working so I am very impressed with
Samsung not only is this very cool very
convenient to not have extra space taken
up it's hidden be able to display but
it's also very secure at the same time
whereas the one that's built into the
sixty by one plus is not that secure so
thank you guys for watching make sure
you guys are subscribed and you guys
have those notifications enabled I will
be switching from my iPhone 10s Macs and
I've been a long time iPhone and Apple
user to the SN Plus and I'll be doing a
follow-up review where I will be letting
you know all of the differences
everything that jumps out at me the good
things and the bad things so make sure
you guys have those notifications
enabled this has been max max tech and I
will see you in the next video